شعبيه كبيره كان يحظى بها الهيب هوب
السعوديه تلك الشعبيه بدات بالتراجع خلال
السنوات الاخيره لدرجه غياب نجومه تماما
على الساحه الاسباب عديده وسنعرف تفاصيلها
مع سهل
[موسيقى]
جدا
ونجومها ما بين الجمهور حيث كانت قبل
سنوات الاكثر انتشارا بين جيل الشباب الا
انها اليوم لم تعد كذلك رقم محاولات لبعض
البقاء في هذا الخط ويطلق اغنيات من هذا
النوع ما بين كل فتره واخرى لكن الامر لم
يعد كذاب السابع
والفنون الجديده
فنيا
الانسان بالبيئته والموسيقى اللي باسمعها
لابد كنت تلمسني بحاجه
الهبوب اللي موجود عندنا مستورد بشكل كامل
ما في اي عناصر محليه لو جينا قارنا مثلا
تجربه في مصر حنلاقيهم بدا ينشهروا لما
بداوا يستخدموا عناصر محليه
لو انت
الاغنيه عباره عن كلمه كاتشي تتكرر بطريقه
حلوه هي هذه الاغنيه
فاذا الكاتب متخصص في شغله ويعرف يكتب
الموزع الموسيقي بيعمل مزيكا حلوه
عالمايك او صوته حلو هي هذه العناصر اللي
تكمل الاغنيه عندنا في الهيب هوب ما في
داخل كافي ان يكون في فريق بيشتغل معاك
وبالتالي تلاقي المغني لحاله هو اللي يدور
ميوزك او هو اللي بيعمل ميوزك بنفسه هو
اللي بيسجل بنفسه واللي
بيحاول انه يطلع بمشروع كامل
طلعت الاولى حلوه الثانيه
قصه ما هو ما هو بسهوله اللي يقدر يعدي
فيكم
[موسيقى]